une petite maison qui fait couler de
l'encré depuis plus de 50 ans avec vue
sur la mer
le rocher du diamant appelé la maison du
bagne à véronique prions diamantino un
plasticien est toujours en admiration
devant la conception de cette
construction
le gagnant avait un certain savoir faire
douter ça c'est sûr ça s'est su le
savait et il avait des idées vous avez
les premières maisons qu'il a
construites
je maintiens loue pas c'est pareil quand
vous pourrez commencer en beauté des
trucs les bains lors qu'ils ont
lorsqu'ils discutent elle est obligée
d'engager tout petit je me replonge en
fait été là j'étais avec lui lorsqu'il a
mené dans un cercle de la maison à la
tête du général
le bateau et c'est au niveau du cou plus
qu un autre couteau direct moi je m'en
doute là la maison du bagnard levrat
d'un martiniquais meda haribo décédé en
1973 banias pas vraiment selon certains
historiens
compte tenu des recoupements que j'ai pu
opérer on peut dire sans se tromper que
médard haribo a été condamné alors par
le bas à niamey à la relégation donc à
cayenne qui est une espèce de peine
complémentaire qui avait été établi en
1885 médard haribo un artiste c'est sûr
condamné ou à voir entre autres sculpté
l'éffigie du colonel coppens
nous sommes en 1925 effigie utilisé en
période électorale très mouvementée
éclater une émeute qui va faire une
dizaine de victimes dont le colonel
coppens absolument contre authenticité
de l'argent du bonheur mais d'un haribo
était selon la municipalité ont reconnu
par son père un congolais s'appelait
donc médard a rit beaucoup nous sa
petite maison lieu d'histoire fierté du
diamant considérablement abîmé en 2014
va bientôt faire l'objet d'une
réhabilitation complète
je n'ai pas le budget précis mais il
faut savoir que aujourd'hui il ya quand
même
on ne peut pas occuper on peut pas
récupérer des objets comme du temps de
mme hidalgo
donc on va réhabiliter les architectes
sont suffisamment avertis pour faire le
nécessaire
ce qui est important de retenir c'est
que il y aura un aménagement global de
ce site avec un parking qui sera
déplacée et vous est ce qu'on appelle un
landau croquis c'est à dire que les les
gens qui vont venir sur ce site pour à
tout moment s'arrêter sur des tables et
pouvoir dessiner
pas de photos portraits de médard ali
beaucoup nous la municipalité promet
également de lancer des recherches en ce
sens